SHARAD: Hey, everyone.
Welcome back.
So in today's video, we're going
to pick up where we left off.
And we finished off,
actually, you can see here,
with pushing this data set using
the table data import wizard,
pushing this Top 10 Songs
data set to our RDS instance.
And so we have all this
data sitting here now,
and everything's great.
Now, you might have
realized that this
was a little bit slow,
though, when we did this.
We pushed-- this is only 28 rows
in this data set, I believe.
And it took about a
minute or so, plus,
way too long to be practical
for any realistic-sized data set
because, again, this is--
it doesn't scale well.
So what I want to show is a
much faster way to do this.
Part of the reason this
is a little bit slow
is, think about
what's happening,
we have this file that's
sitting on our local computer.
That Top 10 Songs CSV
was sitting on my laptop.
I was pushing this
file, or I was basically
uploading this file back to AWS
and trying to push that back
into this structure.
And MySQL itself isn't always
the fastest SQL engine either.
And so there's a lot of piping
that's happening on the backend,
and that is just, in
general, a little bit slower.
We also might have
a situation where
we want to actually use this
data in some practical sense.
Obviously, from here,
I can now bring it down
to my local machine.
But what if I wanted to operate
with this on an EC2 instance?
What if I wanted to work
with this query, this data?
Well, then, if I'm
on an EC2 instance,
I'm just working
on the terminal,
I don't really have the same
kind of interface here with--
playing around with this.
Or if I need to integrate
this with another tool, which
we'll see you in the next video
or the next lecture video--
if I want to integrate
this with another tool,
maybe my website,
hint, hint, then
I need to have this
in another format.
So in today's video,
we're going to do that.
We're going to push,
or a better statement,
we're going to set up
an EC2 instance again,
just the same way we've been
setting up EC2 instances.
And then from there, we're
going to connect to our database
and push this data
to that location.
We're going to push our
data from our EC2 instance
to this table, and we'll see
it's much, much faster this way.
OK, so let's go ahead
and get started then.
So I'm going to pull
this screen up here.
So this is just on the
AWS console under the EC2.
So you could have gotten
here if you search "EC2."
Click there and click
into the "Instances."
Let me pull up my
notes as well, too,
so I make sure I
don't go off track
and start getting
too confusing here.
But basically, what
we want to do first
is just launch an instance.
I'll also actually
say that you could
have technically
done everything we're
about to here on
your local machine,
assuming you have all the
components and everything set up
correctly.
And actually, the
first way I did
this was on my
local machine, but I
figured it would keep the
commands and everything more
consistent if we did this
all on AWS anyways, all
on an EC2 instance.
That way, I know the commands
that I'm running here
are the same
commands that you're
running regardless of what
your computer looks like.
So that's, again, one
of the benefits of this.
So I'll just say "SharadRDSDemo"
for my name on this.
We'll go Ubuntu 20.04.
Everything's going to be exactly
the same as we've been doing.
t2.micro.
I'm going to pick my key pair.
And again, this key pair is
going to be unique to you.
It's going to be
unique to whatever
your computer or whatever
key pair you have downloaded.
Or, if you need to create
a new one, do that.
Under security group, either--
if you can just come here
to the Select security group
and do is3600 security group.
Or you can create security
group and just enable the SSH.
And then we probably
won't need HTTPS,
but we'll need
HTTP at some point.
But either way, if you can do
is3600sg, that works perfectly.
If you're in the Oregon region,
it should work just fine.
So from there, we're going to
have an 8 gig gp2 EBS storage.
So we'll leave that the same.
And then, under the
IAM instance profile,
I'm going to select
this ec2S3 read access.
We're going to download
some data from S3,
and so we need to be
able to read from S3.
So if you go back, actually, in
one of the previous lectures,
you'll see how we created
this ec2S3 read access
if you don't have it there.
But if you have it there,
just go ahead and select that.
And then that should be it.
We can leave everything
else the same.
So let's go ahead and
launch this instance then.
Oh, and I realize I've been just
full screen this whole time,
so let me shrink
myself out of the way.
Hopefully, that was OK to see.
Again, the steps aren't
any different than what
we've been doing, but let
me shrink to this side.
There we go.
So yeah, hopefully, you
can see everything there.
While this is connecting,
I'll run back through it
again, just so you can
see it one more time.
So let me open this up in
a new tab really quick.
Again, name it.
Ubuntu, 20.04,
t2.micro key pair,
network settings-- do select
existing security group
is3600 security
group SG right there,
8 gig, and then ec2 read access,
S3 read access right there.
So we'll do that read access.
We don't necessarily need
full access right now,
so let's just stick with that.
So we'll wait for
this to launch now.
So click into here,
click Connect.
We'll go to copy this
command from the SSH client.
I'm going to open
my terminal here.
Let me clear it out so it's
a little easier to see.
And we'll run that.
Yes, and we're in.
So let me make this
a little bit larger.
So I'm going to start
by doing my sudo apt
update just to make sure all the
packages and libraries are up
to date.
And actually, while
that's running,
there's one more
thing I want to check.
If we go back to our
instance here for a second,
I'm going to scroll
down to Security.
And then what I
want to ensure is
if I go into my inbound rules--
let me see, actually,
is this where I need to?
Ah, actually, no, no, this
is on my RDS instance.
So if you go to RDS--
and the RDS page is, for
whatever reason, very slow.
I haven't figured out why
specifically RDS is so slow,
but either way, this is the RDS
instance I was using last time,
so we're just going to
click into that one.
What I want to ensure is
that when we come down
to security group right here,
this VPC security group,
I'm going to click
that, that RDS SG.
I'm going to look
at my inbound rules.
And then, I'm going to
go to Edit inbound rules.
And what you want to ensure is
that you have this MySQL/Aurora,
which should be default there
when you set up your security
group.
If it's not, go back through,
recreate your security group
or recreate your RDS instance,
and that security group
should be there.
And then also, come in here.
And if you don't have
this All traffic already,
do Add Rule, All traffic.
And then again, it's going
to be the 0.0 this first one.
So just make sure
you have those added.
I already have
that added, so I'm
going to just cancel out of it.
Let me see.
There's my Cancel button.
Sorry, my screen is blocking
my second screen, but yeah.
So just make sure you have
the security group added
to allow all traffic there.
Now we can go back
to our terminal.
And that should
be all up to date.
And so the first thing
we have is we want to--
or we want to ensure,
and actually, RDS
is going to expect
a secure connection.
It's going to do all this
transfer over a secure socket
layer connection.
So it's going to--
we need to have basically
a certificate that
ensures that, hey, we are the--
we're appropriately
qualified, or we've
given the appropriate
permissions
to transfer information
from our local machine,
or from our terminal,
a better statement,
from our EC2 instance,
to this RDS instance.
So it's going to be
expecting the security
certificate on our end.
So if we don't have
it, it won't work.
So the first thing
I'm going to do
is I'm going to make a directory
in my home directory called SSL
for secure socket
layer, and then I'm
going to cd into that directory.
Then, from that, I'm going
to run this Wget command.
I'm just going to
copy and paste this.
This is all in the
lecture 18 notes.
Or you can pause it and type
it in from here, but it's Wget.
And then this space is
not in there too much.
We're going to Wget from
this S3 bucket, this RDS
combined CAbundle.pem.
So again, this is a
security certificate,
similar to how our key pair that
we have to download was a .pem.
So we're just going
to download that,
and that should work just fine.
And then we're going
to go back to our home.
So you can either do the cd..
or the cd tilde.
And now, we want to
create a config file such
that we store our parameters
for our database connection.
So we're going to
do vi config.py.
And this is going to create
this file, this Python file.
And again, I would recommend
copying and pasting this.
We're going to have to
make some changes in here,
but I would just recommend
copying and pasting this
so you don't have to
type everything out.
So we'll do insert,
so i for insert.
And then I'm going to
paste this information.
And so now you want
to come in here
and change your
username, your password.
And so you're going to put the
actual password for your RDS
instance in here.
We're going to
change this endpoint.
And so again, this
endpoint is going
to come from-- if we go back for
a second to our RDS instance.
So this is my RDS
instance again.
It's the same
endpoint we used when
we were connecting to our MySQL
client or MySQL workbench.
So I'm just going to
copy and paste that.
So we're going to remove
this and then paste it there.
So this, again, is
my specific one.
Yours is going to be unique
to your RDS instance,
but your port
should be the same.
We likely haven't
changed to the port.
You only need to make sure
your region is the same.
So if you're in this
US-West-2, this Oregon region,
that's the same.
But if you're using the North
Virginia one-- or, sorry,
the Northern California
one, then it's US-West-1.
If you're using the
North Virginia one,
I think it's US-East-1.
So change that accordingly
for your region
that you're working in.
The database name is
going to be the name
of the database you set up.
So for mine, it was "DemoDB."
You can see right
there, "DemoDB"
was the name of the original
database that I set up.
So I'm going to change
mine to say "demodb."
And then that's what we just
downloaded and created this SSL
directory with the RDS
combined CA bundle.
So that it can stay the same.
And so yeah.
And again, make sure you
change your password.
So I'm going to move
this out of the screen
so you don't see me
typing my password.
This is by no means the
most secure way to do this,
but for this development
test work, it's perfectly OK.
So I'm going to slide out
of the way for a second,
so you can't see
me type this in,
and then I'll Escape
wq to get out of it.
And so once you have
your password in there,
do Escape, colon, wq, and then
you should have it all in here.
So ls, now I can see my SSL
directory and my config.py file.
Now, we need to create a
file to set up the connection
and actually make the
query or run the query.
So it's going to
do both of those
in this next chunk
of Python code.
So we're going to do this by
first just creating a file, so
RDS.
We're going to call
it rds_connection.py.
Nothing fancy here.
And then I will do insert.
And then, similarly, I'm
going to just copy and paste
from the notes here.
I'll walk through what the
code is doing here in a second,
just so you know in
case you are curious.
But if you're not
confident or haven't
seen a lot of
Python code before,
don't worry about
these particulars.
And you're more than
welcome to just run it.
So at a high level, we're
importing this pyMySQL, which we
still need to install pyMySQL.
But we're also then importing
from our config file.
So we're going to import all
the parameters from our config
file such that when we go to
create this start RDS connection
function, we can
just pass those in.
So you see, we're just
passing an endpoint port,
username, password, DBNAME.
All of those are coming
from our config file.
And so this function is just
created to actually start
that connection.
It's saying-- it's
basically my login step.
It's me connecting
to this database.
And so I'm going to do
it in a try except block.
And so again, if you haven't
seen a try and except blocks,
it's OK.
But at a high level,
what it does is it says,
well, try whatever is
in this first chunk
first from this connection.
Basically, just try this
connection function first.
If this connection
function works, great.
Print out that the RDS
connection was successful.
If it wasn't, then
I want you to print
that the connection failed.
And by saying except
the exception as e,
you can see here that we're
doing a formatted string,
and so it's going to tell
me what the error is.
[COMPUTER DINGS]
So this is just saying, hey,
if the connection fails,
tell me why the
connection failed.
Then here, we're
actually going to run it.
So we're going to create this
connection object by calling
start_RDS_connection.
And then, with the
connection.cursor,
we're going to actually just
pass our SQL query into here.
And actually, it's just
select everything on top.
So we're not doing a formatted
string right now, but--
so you can ignore
that for a second.
But either way, we're
just running the query,
select everything from
the top S because we--
or top 10S because it's
not a big data set.
And so cursor.execute, actually
executes that SQL query.
And .fetch_all will retrieve all
the rows that the query should
have returned.
And then, print_result
does exactly what it says.
It prints the result out.
And connection.commit is just
committing that connection.
So this is the whole chunk
to actually run the code.
From this connection
start_RDS_connection down
to connection.commit, that is
what runs the actual query.
So we'll save that.
And so now we need to
actually grab the file
that we want to push up to AWS.
So first order of
business is we need
to ensure that our AWS command
line environment is installed.
So if you need to follow
these steps again--
I will walk through them
right now, obviously.
But I made a note in
there that this is all
coming from that lecture
10 note, the step where
we were downloading our
index.html file from S3.
We're just going to follow the
steps for installing the AWS
command line environment.
So if you're already in your
home directory, it's all good.
If not, just do the cd tilde.
Then we'll do sudo
apt install unzip.
And then we're going to
need to curl this file.
So I'm going to do curl https
awscli, the zip file there.
And we're just going to open it
or save it as "aws_cli_v2.zip."
And then, we're going to
unzip the "aws_cli_v2.zip."
So that's unzipping
all those details.
And then we actually go to
install, so sudo./aws/install.
And so fingers crossed,
that worked correctly.
We can check that
by doing aws s3 ls.
And if you're doing this
on the University account,
you should see this, all
this information here.
If you're doing this on
your personal account,
you won't see any of this.
If you're doing this on
your personal account,
that's one thing I
want to note here.
It's perfectly OK.
You can definitely do that.
Just go ahead and download
this file from Canvas.
Let me make sure, first off,
that it's actually uploaded.
I'll go into Files.
I think it's this.
Let me just ensure that
it's the right file.
Sorry, I probably should
have checked this beforehand,
but this was an issue we
ran into in-person section.
So I just want to ensure
everything looks right.
Yeah, so ec-- county
level ec neighborhood.
Let me make sure both
of them are in there.
So under Files--
I'll drag it up here
so you can see it.
I believe we are
going to-- so you
can see it in the file section.
Yeah, we're going to use this
file, this county level ec
neighborhood.
So again, if you're going to do
this on your own personal AWS
account, that's OK.
Just make sure you upload this
file, this county level ec
neighborhood, to an S3 bucket.
So create an S3 bucket,
upload that there.
And then, I'll show you where we
change that when the time comes.
So let's leave that
back down here.
Let's pull up my
notes once again.
And so once we have
that installed,
then we are going to copy that
file to our local directory,
so sudo aws s3 cp.
And so again, if you're
on the University account,
it'll look exactly like this
data3600demo/county level ec
neighborhood.csv, and then a
period to say copy it here.
If you're on your
own personal account,
you'll likely need to change
what the bucket is called unless
you called your bucket
as well "data3600demo."
So just be mindful of that.
OK.
And so now we have
the file downloaded.
We have our Python code set up.
Now, we just need to install
some packages that can actually
run the things.
There's a couple of
packages that we've imported
or that we've said we
want to import when we run
this function, so
we need to ensure
that we have those packages.
And so to do that, we're going
to go to the lecture 12 notes
and install pip.
So here, I'll pull them
up on the main screen
here so you can see.
So these are the
lecture 12 notes.
And so where are we are here.
Somewhere in here.
I completely scrolled
past it, I think.
All right here.
Yep.
So these steps here, these
three steps just need to be run.
So we can install pip, so we can
pip install our function or all
of our libraries.
So I'll just run through
those one at a time.
So first, we're, just
curling this file,
this .py file from its source.
Then we're going
to do get-pip.py.
[COMPUTER DINGS]
And then we're going
to do this echo.
[COMPUTER DINGS]
All right.
So now we should be
able to continue down
this path of installing
the relevant packages.
So the first package I want to
install is called SQLAlchemy.
And you can look up
all the documentation,
all the crazy things
that SQLAlchemy can do.
But at a high level, it's going
to be one of the ones that's
handling the--
or here, let's just actually go
back to our code for a second.
So it would have been in--
[INAUDIBLE]?
Or maybe I do not
need SQLAlchemy
because I might have changed
some things from when I
originally set this up I think.
Oh, actually, I
think, yeah, it is.
So it actually-- we're going
to use it in a second here.
It's what's actually going
to set up the engine for what
we're doing.
So we're going to do
pip3 install SQLAlchemy.
And then we'll do pip install
py MySQL to get another just SQL
helper package.
And we're going to
pip install pandas
because we're going to import
our dataframe or our CSVs
as pandas dataframes.
And so now we're just
going to go-- we're
going to create one more file.
It's going to be called--
so push_csv_to_db.py.
And then, we are going to copy
and paste this chunk of code
here.
And actually, I
think we can do--
we might be able to do this
a little differently here.
Let's see really quick if
we can get this to work.
We'll do some on-the-fly
coding for a second.
Because right now, I'm going
to have to change all this,
and I don't want to have to
do this because we already
created our config file.
So I think if we do from config
import everything, we can say--
[INAUDIBLE]
So we should be able to do this.
So I apologize if this
code looks like a mess
here in a second.
I'll try to update the
notes if this works,
and so you can just
copy and paste it.
But we want to put a
little quote there.
And then we'll say +, + here.
And this is actually going
to be called "PASSWORD,"
which we're grabbing
from the config file.
Then we'll do another
quotation mark here.
And then this whole chunk--
I think actually we can
always change everything here.
Yeah.
So we'll do-- I'll backspace
this one out first.
We'll leave the '@.'
So it's going to be '@'
+ ENDPOINT + ':' PORT,
and then + a '/' + our DBNAME.
So I think this should work.
If it does, again, you should be
able to just copy and paste it
because I'll have
put it in the notes.
But if not, we'll go back and
change it to what it was before.
But I want to see if we can
make sure this is somewhat
officially as possible.
Oh, and then I
guess technically,
we could have changed the
username as well, too.
The reason I'm doing
this is in the event
that your code is different
or you change the username
or something like
that, you don't
have to worry now that
this code looks different.
This should work
regardless, so USERNAME +.
Everything else
we leave the same,
read_CSV to SQL,
all that good stuff.
Oops.
[COMPUTER DINGS]
And then, wq.
So now, assuming that
worked, we'll try it.
We'll do python3
push_csv_to_db.py.
Ah, I know why.
So let me make this
change really quick.
I'm just showing you guys the
process of debugging here live.
Usually, I'll have
done this in advance,
but sometimes, when I want
to change things on the fly.
So one of these things
was not a string.
And so we want to change.
The username would
have been a string.
That's the string.
Endpoint string is the port.
So let's just see if we call--
if we set this to be a string
this way, does this work?
Oh, yeah, we should probably
call it "PORT," not "ORT."
Let's see.
So there should be a P there.
Hey, look at that.
There we go.
So that was how
fast it pushed it.
If we come back over to here
to our actual database now,
we should be able to see
that if we run "Refresh,"
our database is here now.
So this EC1 will do select rows.
And now all of this data
pushed in a fraction
of a second versus taking
about a minute or so
to push only this much data.
That's really the power of
leveraging SQL with this.
So this is really why I
wanted you guys to see this.
We actually also
technically could have run--
I think this one
should work too.
I forgot to do this
before because we created
that RDS connection file.
So I'm sorry.
That was kind of--
I ran that fast.
So if you do python3
rds_connection.py--
remember that was the file we
created to just do a query.
And so you can see, it ran the
query to select all of the data
from our songs database,
our Top 10 Songs.
So python3 rds_connection
is successful.
It's set up the
connection, and it queried.
And it was that fast.
Again, that quickly
it can query it.
If you wanted to
look at that file,
again, this one was the
one we just ran, and all it
did was run this, select
everything from Top 10 S.
So you could have
changed this query
to be whatever you wanted
to, ran that query,
and/or ran that chunk of code.
And it would have done your
query there as well, too.
So it's exactly the same
as running it over here,
except now we're
doing it in Python.
So yeah, a little
bit involved there.
Definitely take your time.
Go back through this.
Let me clear this out so
you can see a little easier.
Definitely take your time.
Go back through this.
Make sure it makes sense.
We're going to extend on
this in the next video
and actually connect
this to a web API,
like we have done in the past.
And that's really
going to be where
you see a lot of the flexibility
introduced with this approach.
One last note-- whenever
we're done with this,
and you're more than welcome
to watch that, or wait
till you watch the next
video and run it that way,
or do it at that time.
But I'd like you to also
make sure you delete your RDS
instance, because
these do cost money.
They're not cheap.
They're running 20 gigs
of storage on them.
So whenever you're
done with this,
you've done all the steps and
everything, come under here
under Actions and click Delete.
You won't need to
create a final snapshot,
so you can uncheck that.
You won't need to retain
automated backups,
so you can uncheck that.
You'll acknowledge that
once you delete this,
you're losing all snapshots and
backups, and you'll click that.
And then, you'll type
"delete me" and hit Delete.
Now, I'm not going
to delete mine
because I'm going to
record the next video,
so you guys have
that to go from.
But whenever you're
done with both of these,
make sure you do that step.
So we'll leave it at that.
A relatively short video, but
a lot of content in there.
So please, please,
take your time with it.
Come ask me questions.
Try things out, and then
we'll go from there.
OK, have a good one,
and see you next time.
Bye.